俺今
ルークスやってるように見えるだろう
これね
猫背直しグッズなんだよ
お兄ちゃん歯止め社長です皆さんちょうちょ知っていますか
羽生えているちょちょっといってことが結構世界中でよく見かけられると思うんです
けども
そのちょうちょのおもちゃがありましてみなさんに今回ご紹介したいと思いますじゃあ
マジックまたくらい近くで見ると結構ねぇそのマンではディセもんちゃんってなると
思うんですけどもう遠くから見ると後にちょっとなんですよってこのマジックパターン
がどんなものかといいますと青まくるるっとまあ
明日って本当かに挟むコーンを開けた瞬間パトパーって町長のとってるやつでござい
ますプレゼ犬っていいでしょ
頬を止めてまわすだけでいいんですよあけまして本当に来て挟んで
床に置く取っておいた方を挙げると
もう一回やろかクルッと押して開けます次ました
う
一周するねぇねぇパパいいじゃないなんだ猫がついたらこれは結構巻かなきゃいけない
んだから南紀が良かったらおすすめですこれだけ牧場多分
をソロ酔狂で出てくんだと思います
はあああこれはこれだけ同キャラ動画凄さはなやつです
三松つ1通1
ほぼを開いてきて今回このちょっと大量に準備しました
僕は知っているんです結局瞬発力であるものって面白いということだって言うけど今
大量のここで飛んで行くと大
とっとと待てまで大量の町長があるんですけどそれ多分本当に挟まなくてもっと
パソコンの隙間とかに日間でおけば飛んで行くと思うんですよ
ここにあるマジ
ブーバたして受けたらぱてぃんくって調査ティックってどうなると思いますでを作っ
てくよ
自社やるじゃんよってここで難しいのは今から五大老ちょうちょ全部泣いて泣いて泣い
てここに入れてくっていうのはまず難しいと思うんですと頑張ります1枚
何水を汲むず僕のムズイ ok
[音楽]
バーン
ん
いやーもダメ入りないんだこれ
やだもー物理的限界が迫ってきておりますかもう無理だもう入んないです見えます
でしょうか
macbook の中にひしひしと長女が挟まっておりますもう拝領地はありません
ごめんなさいなんてこれでもさぁもぱっと見てすぐわかっちゃうよねと指で10
して早速ターゲットを4ねここに座らせてアソコを開いたら who are
長とたちがフーマーでライガー
[音楽]
ん
入ってくる
持っています
ran
今一つですねはい
何言った江連ちゃんっ
wai 学校5分
パソコン望みすごいお揃いで持ってあげるみてください痛くないですよねあジャパンと
はぁっ
wh
[音楽]
ブーバー
macha macha
[音楽]
ええええええええええええ
大まあまあ音楽
びっくりしたーーあっはぁ
バッハ